[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández y
hoy los llevaremos a Chile
Quién no sueña con comprar una isla
desierta este deseo se puede hacer
realidad en el archipiélago de chiloé
pagando unos 1.7 millones de dólares
sitios web venden Islas Vírgenes en
piscinas y remotas áreas de la Patagonia
chilena algunas de casi 45.000 hectáreas
la venta ha generado es tu por entre los
chilotas como se les llama a los
pobladores el archipiélago de chiloé los
posibles compradores son
multimillonarios las hoteleras o la
industria salmonera las comunidades
indígenas tienen miedo de que personas
ajenas a su geografía se hagan Dueñas el
patrimonio histórico ancestral económico
ecológico y biocultural Patricia Luna
realizó este reportero y nos acompaña
hoy para contarnos más los detalles
sobre las ventas de las Islas les saludo
Patricia Patricia Cuál es la
preocupación que se vive entre las
comunidades indígenas que habitan cerca
de estas islas en venta
pues estas comunidades basculan entre la
indignación la rabia pero también la
resignación ante lo que está ocurriendo
en el archipiélago que es también un
reflejo de algo que sucede en el resto
del país se trata de una zona de la
Patagonia Norte donde existen Islas que
podrían ser habitadas pero que no han
sido habitadas por cuestiones
espirituales porque estas Islas tienen
un vínculo ancestral con muchas de las
comunidades indígenas que las habitan en
esta área donde los pobladores tienen un
carácter anfibios muy importante son
fiordos y está la presencia de la tierra
pero también la presencia del mar y han
utilizado de forma ancestral estas Islas
como forma de subsistencia para ir a
Mariscal para obtener mariscos para
obtener algas con la que luego vender y
poder por ejemplo educarse entre muchas
otras temas es por tanto una cuestión
bastante cercana a las poblaciones
indígenas que ven con mucha preocupación
como estas Islas que tienen este
significado tan profundo para ellos
salen a la venta por cantidades
exorbitantes de dinero
Gracias Patricia ya volvemos contigo
aquí la historia
[Música]
es el sueño de muchos ser propietario de
una isla desierta sitios web
norteamericanos chilenos y prestigiosas
casas británicas venden Islas Vírgenes
en piscinas y remotas áreas de la
Patagonia chilena los posibles clientes
multimillonarios hoteleras o la
industria salmonera
siloé es uno de los archipiélagos
poblados más grandes en Chile al menos
tres de sus más de 40 Islas están ahora
a la venta en otras regiones de la
Patagonia en el extremo Sur se venden
islas de casi 45.000 hectáreas
es una reconocida trabajadora de la
salud y una autoridad de la comunidad
mapuche
hoy se reencontró con amigas y
dirigentes sociales para visitar la isla
de imelec alarmadas porque se está
ofertando en una coma siete millones de
dólares una cantidad muy por encima de
las posibilidades económicas de los
habitantes de la zona
permiso
permiso Hola buenas tardes
22 años que no vengo a
dudarme un poco un poquito de nostalgia
a recordar toda mi niñez y mi juventud
la vivimos todos los veranos trabajando
en la nuca ahí para seguir estudiando
para poder pagar comprar los útiles
escolares la ropa los zapatos y para los
hermanos que quedaron en la casa
la emoción se apodera de flor a medida
que se aproxima a la isla de su
adolescencia
las tres mujeres rinden homenaje a los
Espíritus de la isla y les piden permiso
para entrar en ella con un mapuche
[Música]
emelec tiene para las comunidades
indígenas un carácter sagrado que es en
parte responsable de que no hayan sido
habitadas por siglos Islas como esta han
sido utilizadas milenariamente como
lugares para extraer mariscos o algas
como forma de subsistencia
tenemos que defender esto tenemos que
defenderlo porque es algo nuestro es
algo que llevamos acá en nuestro que
nuestro corazón entonces hoy día venir
acá y
volverme a meterla los pies en el agua
sentir ese
esa fuerza que hay acá es muy es muy
sanadora en la isla es un tesoro para
nosotros
Así que no creo que por ningún motivo
que lo venda así como a otra
extranjero que invaden que o que quizás
sí la cuiden pero ya no tengamos esta
libertad de llegar
Aunque la isla de sus recuerdos también
ha sufrido cambios en los últimos años
la naturaleza viene recobrando su
espacio por ejemplo acá pero debajo está
entera contaminada
mire cómo está
y así está nuestra
nuestras mares en nuestra
nuestras playas la mayoría que insinuó
el producto de la salmonera eso ha hecho
también que muchos mariscos se vayan
desapareciendo con los peces vayan
desapareciendo por culpa de la
contaminación
la atención en Chile entre las
comunidades indígenas y pesqueras
artesanales y la Industria Del salmón
salta a la vista en cada Rincón de sus
miles de lagos y pequeñas bahías
alguien que conoce bien sobre esto es el
geógrafo y activista ambiental Álvaro
montaña de la asociación defendamos
chiloé los mapas de este académico han
sido fundamentales en los procesos de
solicitar la protección del borde
costero para las comunidades indígenas
gran parte de estas pequeñas Islas que
hoy se venden en internet el entorno
Marino ha sido contaminado y ha sido
solo explotado por la industria
salmonera es originado atenciones
conflictos también con las comunidades
locales que dependen de la pesca
artesanal de la extracción de marisco de
la extracción de algas
el geógrafo muestra en el mapa en rojo
la densidad de salmoneras en la zona
hoy día las comunidades indígenas de
chiloé son mapuches mapuche
han solicitado espacios costeros para
salvaguardar los valores escénicos
ecológicos y culturales para resguardar
lo poco que va quedando además libre de
privatización pero en un estado
ecológico sumamente degradado en apenas
tres décadas de expansión de la
Industria del cholito mejillón y del
salmón
en los 90 se introdujo en la Patagonia
el cultivo de peces y mariscos que han
situado a Chile a la cabeza Hoy es el
segundo productor de salmones del mundo
y el primer exportador de mejillones
el carácter de archipiélago de chiloé
queda reflejado en la forma en que viven
muchos de sus habitantes la mayoría de
orígenes Humildes
Aquí los barcos funcionan como un
sistema de buses para abastecer de lo
que necesitan a los que viven en Islas
donde existen las famosas Iglesias
chilotas patrimonio de la humanidad Pero
ni una sola tienda
Esteban Molina pertenece a una familia
de lancheros que diariamente conecta
gente en estas Islas le duele
profundamente lo que está ocurriendo en
su territorio
como isleño nacidos y criados aquí no
podemos creer que estén en venta
nuestras Islas
no podemos creer que el gobierno no se
haga cargo de controlar esta avalancha
de promociones de terreno de sectores
Rurales y vemos por internet en los
correos en las radios en las redes
sociales
lotes y lotes de terreno en venta y sin
tener ninguna regulación
que estemos en este nivel de atraso
quedas como te sientes como de manos
atadas porque no hay quien te puede
ayudar con contra esto que el peso del
dinero vamos nos va a terminar dejando
sin agua sin espacio creo que es el
sentimiento predominante sentimos que
nos robaron
sí le cuentas con más de 43.000 Islas
más de la mitad de ellas son privadas el
Ministerio de bienes nacionales del
gobierno de Gabriel boric declinó
participar en este reportaje
argumentando que al ser territorios
privados no tienen ninguna injerencia
Carol oriunda de la Bahía de caulín
tiene sus recuerdos de infancia
asociados a la isla de la cao ahora la
venta en páginas web extranjeras
incluida la lujosa casa de subastas
Carol trata de transmitir las enseñanzas
ecológicas de su infancia a su hijo
Damián
el concejal de ancud Pedro nahuil es
dirigente indígena al igual que
Francisco Vera que pertenece a la mesa
de protección de la zona costera
ambos representan algunas de las más de
10 comunidades mapuches asociadas a la
isla de la cao que descubrieron con
estupor hace solo tres años y por la
prensa que la isla donde los colonos
españoles ajusticiaron a sus ancestros
quemando los vivos para liarse con
holandeses contra ellos está a la venta
La Isla fue donada un militar durante la
dictadura de Augusto pinochet aunque se
desconocen las causas de esta
transferencia de tierras fue una
práctica repetida en otros lugares del
país esta Isla a salvo por el momento
del peligro de la salmoneras tiene un
importante valor medioambiental
podemos
observar una gran diversidad de fauna de
fauna nativa
también una gran cantidad de aves
migratorias que vienen a la Bahía de
caulín aquí la isla también tiene un
humedal dentro donde anidan los cisnes
anidan las Garza las gaviotas anidan las
pachancas
y un sinfín de aves para nosotros sería
lamentable cierto que esta Isla pasará a
manos de otro privado
para nosotros es extraño ya porque la
gran mayoría de islas del archipiélago
no no están en manos de un solo
propietario Generalmente están en manos
de las familias que han hecho cierto que
han habitado y han hecho patrias en este
territorio desde hace siglos
Francisco también conoce los secretos de
las hierbas sus ojos humedecen al hablar
de la venta de la isla en la que acusa
falta de transparencia en chile no hay
un catastro Público de propiedad de
tierras ni tampoco una ley de
ordenamiento territorial que permita
protegerlas
Mira las comunidades y la vinculación
que tiene con esta isla por ser un
territorio ancestral y Ella guarda
muchos secretos del año 1500 a 1600
donde hubieron sacrificios de nuestros
ancestros
la venta de La Isla para nosotros es un
golpe duro
muy duro
si se vende La Isla el temor nuestro es
perder
una gran cosmovisión gran unas grandes
sería perder nuestra cultura porque aquí
hay muchas cosas todavía ancestralmente
que nosotros y los indígenas que estamos
Hoy día hay recursos en que nosotros nos
sirven a nosotros para poder sobrevivir
en otra zona de La Isla Carol revive sus
recuerdos de infancia y se frustra al
saber que si se vendiera su hijo no
podría dividir las experiencias que ella
evoca con tanta nostalgia
finalmente las Islas o sea nos pertenece
a todos como comunidad claro me genera
rabia porque no se hace nada no se hace
nada de parte del gobierno para
resguardar estas Islas que están en
venta me da miedo que mi hijo no
disfrute de
los momentos maravillosos que yo vivía
acá en la isla de enseñarle tradiciones
ancestrales
los tres miembros de la comunidad tienen
un Genuino interés por la conservación
ecológica y se aterran al descubrir
cisnes muertos les preocupa si los
ecosistemas podrán seguir
desarrollándose en este lugar en caso de
que la isla resulte vendida y pueda ser
sometida a depredación humana
este lo está todo conmigo donde los
perros lo mataron lo comieron y las aves
de rapiña raparon El huesito lo dejaron
limpio
la Data de muerte no es más allá de una
semana
en las últimas semanas nuevas Islas
chilenas de mayor tamaño aparecieron a
la venta en Las web también en páginas
de Manhattan se venden terrenos de más
de 100.000 hectáreas más al sur de la
Patagonia que incluyen una biodiversidad
única bosques nativos Valles montañas
ríos y lagos la incertidumbre continúa
creciendo en las comunidades casi
siempre indígenas que han poblado de
forma comunitaria desde siempre esos
territorios y que se ven amenazadas de
ser expulsadas de nuevo 500 años después
estamos de vuelta con Patricia Patricia
pero las Islas no son los únicos
territorios chilenos que están en venta
qué más podemos saber sobre este tema
el tema de la venta de las Islas que
apareció un poco antes de la pandemia
puso de manifiesto que en chile hay
grandes terrenos grandes zonas de
territorio especialmente en la Patagonia
grandes Islas no solo en chiloé sino
también en la Patagonia Sur en la región
de Magallanes y dicen donde se ponen no
solo Islas a la venta sino también
parques Valles lagos montañas en las
últimas semanas ha habido una polémica
en torno a una provincia en la que se
ofrece 130.000 hectáreas un tercio de
esa provincia está a la venta al mejor
postor en casas como christies en Nueva
York para que aquellas personas que
dispongan del suficiente dinero puedan
adquirir una parte del territorio
chileno que contiene bosques nativos
lagos Incluso en ocasiones glaciares
esto también levanta la indignación no
solo de los habitantes de la Patagonia
sino en general de todo chile mientras
el gobierno afirma que al tratarse de
terrenos de origen no pueden hacer nada
al respecto
Nos despedimos de Patricia hasta aquí
reporteros de la semana recuerde que
para sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima